all right everybody it is time for
drew's news sit back relax and kick up
your feet on your good news ottoman
with me at the desk is the one the only
rosty ross matthew yeah hi
everybody hi
hi
sorry i gotta clean my glasses i love
this bright electric blue on you today
you do yeah i tried to like you know you
mean like you're a bright electric blue
yeah well yeah but i just like hop on
the the drew train we're like that
couple we're totally that couple of
matches all right well
boy am i happy about this breaking movie
news
we're getting a nancy
myers movie thank god
you guys
nancy myers is responsible for oh gosh i
mean baby boom baby boom's at the top of
my list of course i have a list here
father of the bride it's complicated the
holiday
something's got to give and that's just
a few of them
i know funny enough i was in a movie
that her and her husband directed called
the reconcilable differences oh my god i
worked with nancy back in the day um so
she went into retirement she said i'm
done i'm not making movies and we all
cried yeah um but deadline just
literally reported that netflix of
course brilliant inked a deal with the
legendary filmmaker to write direct and
produce a brand new comedy now we have
no idea what it's about or what format
it'll be in it's just that it's an
original ensemble comedy it'll be
nancy's first movie since 2015 when she
made the intern with robert de niro and
anne hathaway i mean i am chomping at
the bit this was hot news to me uh and
i'm already um obsessed with this movie
and it hasn't even been written yet so
thank you nancy myers all right
speaking of movies we were so thrilled
when troy kotzer won the oscar for best
supporting actor for coda
becoming
the first deaf man to ever win an oscar
for acting
and then coda won best picture i know i
love that movie
without variety reports troy recently
celebrated his love of movies by
recreating some of the most iconic lines
in movie history in american sign
language i literally think that he is
just everything i love him so much and
i am so happy to see him doing stuff
like this it's just such a delight he's
so wonderful he's so wonderful and he
was so great in this movie if you
haven't seen cody uh watch it he'll make
you cry but he will also make you laugh
did you see what he posted on twitter no
this is so cute
i ever wonder how people get their oscar
home after they win it like do can you
put it in the overhead i have never
no no i've never had to worry about that
well not yet but so this is how he got
his oscar home he tweeted this picture
look he drove it home and he buckled it
in how cute he had like a six-hour road
trip after the oscars and i just thought
that was so cute okay this is exactly
what i'm talking about like can he get
any more wonderful he's the most
charming
wonderful person now i've got that
visual when i have god it doesn't stop
what we'll see next we got i can't wait
to see
[Music]